la politique agricole commune c'est
l'une des discussions qui étaient au
coeur des échanges de l'union européenne
ces derniers jours au luxembourg un
accord sur la réforme de cette politique
a été trouvé par les 27 ministres
européens de l'agriculture
cette nouvelle orientation se
matérialise par des normes strictes en
matière de protection de l'environnement
que les agriculteurs doivent respecter
une pac plus verte selon le ministère
français de l'agriculture
après de nombreuses heures de
négociations nous avons obtenu un accord
qui correspond aux attentes fortes de la
france des mesures environnementales
obligatoire pour tous les états membres
permettant d'éviter toute distorsion de
concurrence c'est donc une pac plus
verte et mais surtout plus juste c'était
une demande forte de la france
un projet qui comprend l'investissement
de 387 milliards d'euros d' aide aux
agriculteurs et qui doit entrer en
vigueur dès janvier 2023 pour une
période de sept ans il s'agit du premier
secteur de dépenses de l'ue eux
du côté européen on met également en
avant une réussite
après de longues discussions il y à
quelques heures à peine nous avions des
opinions très divergentes
il s'agit d'une bonne nouvelle pour nos
agriculteurs qui ont besoin d'une
sécurité de planification pour les
prochaines années beaucoup d'argent en
jeu et des règles environnementales plus
contraignantes pour les exploitations
une orientation politique qui est loin
de faire l'unanimité
la pac qu'on nous propose pour 2023 ne
propose rien de nouveau elle est dans la
continuation des précédentes
elle va donc continuer à provoquer des
désastres mais elle correspond aux
attentes des grands lobbys qui entoure
et profite des agriculteurs le lobby
agro chimique et le lobby
agroalimentaire qui sont les principaux
bénéficiaires d'une agriculture
productiviste
elle représente plus d'un tiers du
budget total de l'union européenne s'est
énormément d'argent public
donc cela nous concerne toutes et tous
pour autant rien n'est encore gagné
ce nouveau plan doit être voté par les
eurodéputés ce vendredi un vote final
qui sera suivie d'une négociation entre
le parlement la commission et les états
membres dans l'objectif d'un accord de
conseil
r d'ici le début des années 2000 21 des
discussions et des échanges qui
s'annonce mouvementée